[Applause]
[Music]
on this day
we gather because we have chosen hope
over fear
there are some who question the scale of
our ambitions
who suggest that our system cannot
tolerate too many big plans
their memories are short for they have
forgotten what this country has already
done
what free men and women can achieve when
imagination has joined the common
purpose
[Music]
we are going to need you not just today
not just tomorrow but this year for the
next four years and who knows after that
because together we are going to change
[Music]
america
[Music]
we'd gotten a call from the white house
saying that they would like
us to take a red-eye flight to fly out
there
and we thought they were joking so like
my grandma i think hung up on them the
first time
i actually thought somebody was pulling
a prank
call because it was the white house
[Music]
as soon as we touched ground there was
somebody waiting for us to rush us to
the white house because our flight got
in at like
6 20 in the morning
and was due to kick off at 8 am
the first person i saw walking in when i
walked in was obama
i thought wow that's crazy
mr president i i think we got a happy
room here
there were so many people who were so
excited
today after almost a century of trying
today after over a year of debate
today after all the votes have been
tallied
[Music]
health insurance reform becomes law in
the united states of america
i was originally i was in the back like
behind everybody so i wasn't at the
front
originally because the place that i was
in the picture was where
joe biden was originally going to be so
he had moved them and then put me right
there
and then as he was signing joe biden
leaned over my shoulder and told me to
watch the pins
go by as he was signing it
and i was just watching the pins go by
as he was signing it
and like saw his name slowly like coming
onto the page
[Music]
when he finished the signing he turned
to me
and looked at me i think i was the first
person he had shaken
hands with after that
early on in his presidency the
republicans
met in a restaurant determined to to
stop him at all costs
whatever he proposed they were going to
stop
the and and not only that but
they told the american people this which
is the most bizarre thing is that
senator mcconnell came out and said our
goal is to make him
a one-term president there were no ifs
ands and buts about it
our top political priority over the next
two years should be to deny president
obama a second term
when the head of the senate says the
number one job is to
make obama a one-term president not the
economy
not health care not the environment
not crime your number one job is to stop
the first black man for being president
on the second term that sends a message
in the end he did get the legislation
through but just barely
it reads like something that was brought
up in the early 1930s in germany
i've heard that one republican
strategist told his party that even
though they may want to compromise
it's better politics to go for the kill
this isn't about me i have great health
insurance
and so does every member of congress
it was a much harder task than i think
he ever envisioned
for for a couple of reasons one being
that he thought that if he gave a little
he thought that he could work the
republicans on this
he didn't realize that the political
factions were as strong in washington as
they were
he inherited a financial crisis that was
you know nothing that we had seen since
the 1930s
entire sectors of the u.s economy were
hanging in the balance
the banks were in failure and i don't
know that we
really understand how monumental a task
that he had
800 000 americans are losing their jobs
a month and it's very hard to be a great
power abroad
when you're collapsing here at home
[Music]
you know the economy was still in free
fall taking on
health care reform is something that
perplexed a lot of people
it perplexed his own advisors taking on
health care
is just an issue we don't need right now
why do this let's get the economy
roaring again and spend our political
capital on that
mercy was seven
when my daughter felt ill she got sick
and she had to start missing work to
try to get herself better but
she started missing too much work so
eventually she got fired from her job
and then in turn lost her health care
so she wasn't able to go get the care
that she needed
marcy was really bitter and angry
she wound up passing away in 2007 on
june 18.
she didn't have to pass the way she did
[Music]
we tried to get her on medicaid
the state told us tiffany didn't qualify
because she had worked for a full year
prior
so tiffany was stuck with no health care
marcellus lost his mom to an illness and
she didn't have insurance
and couldn't afford the care that she
needed so in her memory
he has told her story across america so
that no other children
have to go through what his family's
experienced
this is a man who wanted equal
opportunities
for everyone this is a man who
didn't stop at any one group of persons
or people to get something across
everything he did has helped
every human being across our nation
[Music]
is there one thing from that day that
always sticks in your mind
um
yes the look in obama's eyes when he
looked at mercy after signing the bill
that look of him
telling mercy without using words
this is you and me kid
that was a moment i'll never forget
[Music]
it was one of the greatest things that
ever happened to me in my life
because i always have wish
that i could go to the white house
i didn't think i'd ever live to see
like president virginia
[Music]
[Music]
we're so
[Music]
i enjoyed that day oh i've been happy
ever since
[Music]
all my life dancing with him and
being in the white house i'll never
forget it
i will never forget that
and seeing the black man and the ruling
stuff
i'll never forget because i didn't think
that it would ever
[Music]
i enjoyed that day
just electing a black president isn't
going to solve all of our racial
problems in fact it may have even
divided us a little more what his
election did
was pull the cover off of ugly cancer in
america
that people have been covering up
we don't have a race relations problem
you've got a racism problem
they have an oppression problem they
have a discrimination problem have a
hate problem
over the last eight years we've we've
had a lot of racial incidents in our
country
that um we didn't have before obama
whether that's all due to him i don't
know the police shootings
of of young african-american men that
have been caught on video
he's had to deal with that as
the leader of our country we need to
recognize that the situation
in ferguson speaks to broader challenges
that we still face as a nation
the fact is in too many parts of this
country
a deep distrust exists between law
enforcement and communities of color
there are some things that the president
has communicated without ever
saying a word when he gives a guy a fist
pump
or just does that swag that he does when
he walks in the room
he is quite aware of what that is
and the folk who don't have it really
hate him for it i call that envy and
jealousy
it shouldn't hate they should celebrate
but because of that
much is what he's done has always been
subject to
your interpretation based on your
experience and there are a lot of white
men
who are envious and hateful of barack
obama only because he's so cool so
smooth so smart to intelligent
he is the living dichotomy for them
[Music]
9-1-1 what's the address of the
emergency please emmanuel church there's
plenty of people
shot down here please send somebody
right away emmanuel
church and there's people shot yeah he
shot the pastor he shot
all the men in the church please come
right away did you see him at all
yes he's a young 21 year old white dude
there's so many people dead i think
oh my god you said there's so many
people dead
i think they're dead
when you hear about tragedies in other
places you're kind of far removed from
it
but when you're actually in the city
and you know not just one of the persons
but you know all of them and their
family members
that really hits home then
dylan roof killed black people
and he went to where they were not
because
of their faith he went because he knew
one the church was significant in his
own
words and because he knew there would be
black people then it wouldn't be a lot
of them
be just enough to kill
to the families of the fallen the nation
shares in your grief
our pain cuts that much deeper because
it happened in a church
the church is and always
has been the center of african-american
life
[Applause]
a place to call our own in a too often
hostile world
[Music]
a sanctuary from so many hardships
destiny would have it i just happen to
be sitting at the organ
listening to the president's message and
all we could really see really was
really the back of his head
amazing grace
i sweep the sound
and save the rich like me
i once was lost but now i'm found
was blind but now i
[Music]
then everybody starts chiming in the
sound
[Music]
amazing grace is one of those hymns
that really touches the young the old
male female
and no matter who sings it it's a
personal
testimony for any individual who sings
it
to how great and amazing god's grace is
i once
was lost but now
i'm found
was blind but
now i
see
[Music]
he kind of paused and kind of looked
down one time and then
he started singing and everyone just
kind of looked at each other
and we said oh start singing so
i just kind of closed my eyes said a
quick prayer i said okay we're gonna go
with it
and i guess he said the rest is history
how sweet
[Music]
find me
[Music]
just to see the joy
on people's faces to hear the cheers and
to see the tears
just a moment of pure joy
a decade ago politicians ran against
lgbt rights
today they're running towards them all
right
[Applause]
john my partner of almost 21 years was
dying of als
motor neuron disease and he was in at
home hospice care and i was his primary
caregiver
all we were looking for was dignity and
respect
on june 26 2015 when the supreme court
ruled
in obergevie hodges they said that the
constitution demands
that every american regardless of
sexual orientation deserves
and has the right to marry the person
they love and that
all the states must recognize those
lawful marriages
the marriage equality is about our civil
rights
and our firm belief that every citizen
should be treated equally under the law
so they hand me this telephone on
speaker in the midst of this huge crowd
and it's the president
the uh i figured when i saw you then we
were going to be hoping for some good
news and we did
and i just wanted to say congratulations
thank you so much sir i think it was
your wishes
you know your your uh your leadership on
this
you know has changed changed the country
i was in that spot i ended up in that
place because i loved my husband and i
wanted to fight for him
and then to get a call from the
president you know in the midst of this
loud cheering crowd trying to hear him
on a speaker phone
and hanging up and
every interviewer after that asking me
what he said or what i said and all i
could say was
i have no idea it's really been an honor
for me to
be involved in this fight and to have
been able to
you know fight for my marriage and live
up to my commitments to my husband
so i appreciate i appreciate everything
you've done
for the lgbt community and it's really
an honor to
to have become part of that fight well
yeah i'm really proud of you and uh
you know just just know that
you know not only have you been a great
example for people but uh
you're also gonna you know uh bring
about a lasting change in this country
and it's uh it's pretty rare where that
happens
so i couldn't be prouder of you and
your husband and god bless you for me as
an american citizen to see
the the most important person in our
nation
say i matter and for my family and
friends to hear
him say that you can't calculate
the impact that that has
so
[Music]
my friend called she said it's
a shooting and it's at our school
[Music]
i just collapsed to the floor
and my classmates picked me up one of
them bundled me into a car
and we started the drive to sandy hook
as we got closer there were cars
everywhere people were just abandoning
their cars and running
but i couldn't see dylan anywhere
and i just assumed dylan was hiding um
or that he'd run off because he's
autistic and the loud noises would have
scared him or that mrs murphy was
holding him somewhere and protecting him
then after a while they asked all the
parents that were still there
to go into the back room
some people were crying most of us were
just kind of lost
[Music]
and then uh and then governor malloy
came he broke the
silence that and said the things that no
one wanted to say
if you're still in this room waiting for
your loved one it means they're not
coming back to you
and he talked about how many children
had been shot and killed
um he told us that two had been taken to
hospital but had
had died on route um
and uh and the place just
erupted um there was screaming and
wailing
and and i just shut down i just
completely shut down
the majority of those who died today
were children
[Music]
beautiful little kids between the ages
of 5 and 10 years old
they had their entire lives ahead of
them birthdays
graduations weddings
kids of their own
[Music]
among the fallen were also teachers men
and women who devoted their lives to
helping our children
fulfill their dreams so our hearts are
broken today
and what mother can you can't accept
that your child is dead it's
it's not it's not something that your
heart or your brain can understand
i couldn't accept it and there's a part
of me still today that doesn't accept it
because it's impossible to believe that
he's not part of my life anymore and
even now
you know it's four years later and i'll
still find myself looking in the
rearview mirror
trying to see if he's in his car seat
that's not going to go away
we decided that we wanted to go and hear
what the president had to say
so we agreed to
meet with the with the president
privately
no cameras no media
it was just a very private conversation
i remember when the president
um came into our room
the first thing he asked was about dylan
you know
he he knew the names
of everyone he wanted to see pictures
he wanted us to talk about dylan
he hugged me very very tightly i
remember my dad
saying you know mr president you have
the power to do something you have to
do something about this and uh
and the president said um
i will i will do something
surely we can do better than this
if there's even one step we can take to
save another child
or another parent or another town
then surely we have an obligation to try
we can't accept
events like this as routine
are we really prepared to say that we're
powerless
in the face of such carnage
[Music]
that the politics are too hard i think
him coming to newtown
and doing his speech in the new town
high school meeting the families
showed how personally touched he was by
this and how
personally committed he was to
not letting this happen again
i think the the moment the moment that i
recall the most
is when he read out all the names um
and honestly there was a part of me that
was still hoping dylan's name
wasn't on the list charlotte
daniel olivia
josephine anna
dylan but hearing him say all 26 names
catherine that's the moment that
probably sticks with me
most because it wasn't just
a group of children or a group of
educators
he was speaking about them as people and
as individuals
the only thing that stops a
bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun
emily jack
noah caroline
jessica
[Music]
the a's are 54 the nays are 46
under the previous order requiring 60
votes for the adoption of this amendment
the amendment is not agreed to
a minority in the united states senate
decided
it wasn't worth it they blocked
common-sense gun reforms
even while these families looked on from
the senate gallery
i think it probably is the biggest
disappointment of his presidency
because he just wanted to do
the right thing he wanted to
provide something that could help others
and deliver on his promises our
expressions
of grief and our commitment to do
something different
to prevent these things from happening
are not empty words
he was angry so all in all this was a
pretty shameful day for washington
it was a congress that just wasn't going
to allow him to
get anything through and if the loss of
a couple of dozen children to gun
violence
isn't enough to
change our gun laws in our country i
don't know what
what will do it if there was a darkest
day in his presidency that might have
been it
every time i think about those kids it
gets me mad
barack obama is not a pacifist
there's a caricature of him as kind of a
tweety academic constitutional lawyer
doesn't know what he's doing doesn't
want to hurt anyone
doesn't want to go to war view and
that's that's that's wrong
he is in many ways a stone cold killer
he's killed more terrorists and more
countries than any american president
has ever done
tonight i can report to the american
people and to the world
that the united states has conducted an
operation that killed
osama bin laden the leader of al qaeda
and a terrorist who's responsible for
the murder of thousands
of innocent men women and children
nearly 3 000 citizens taken from us
leaving a gaping hole in our hearts no
one was ever going to reach the
presidency who did not want
to kill bin laden we have been able to
decimate
the ranks of al qaeda we were able to
finally bring
osama bin laden to justice
[Music]
the united states for a variety of
reasons was not seen as a source of
inspiration or hope for
many in the world
if there's a theme to the last 16 years
the theme is this
george w bush uh his administration
was a demonstration of the perils of
overreaction and
barack obama's administration his
foreign policy could be
understood as a testament to the perils
of underreaction
[Music]
good afternoon everybody today the
entire world
is appalled by the brutal murder of jim
foley by the terrorist group isil
i found out when an hysterical
ap journalist called me saw being on the
phone
that's how i found out jim was a
journalist
a son a brother and a friend
i mean jim was held nearly two years
nearly starved to death in the first
year he was taken
hostage nearly two years ago in syria
and he was
courageously reporting at the time on
the conflict there
the isis captor is incredibly
cruel in even a mental way you know
emotional way right they're really
trying to inflict a lot of pain and
panic on the part of us
and their hostages he reported from
difficult and dangerous places bearing
witness to the lives of people
a world away jim always
just had a heart for those who were
vulnerable
and who really didn't have a voice
today the american people will all say a
prayer for those who love jim
all of us feel the ache of his absence
all of us mourn his loss
we keep in our prayers those other
americans who are separated from their
families
we will do everything that we can to
protect our people
and the timeless values that we stand
for
may god bless and keep jim's memory and
may god bless the united states of
america
i had not felt that the government had
the back of our son that was appalling
to me as an american
i just i thought oh we could do better
than that
i don't think there's any way around the
fact that syria will be a stain on his
legacy
president obama was trying to avoid more
confrontation in the middle east
but sadly by not engaging with some of
what was happening
it did worsen because there was a void
that we did not feel that
some of the jihadist groups were very
quick to fill
[Music]
my fellow americans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michelle and i have been so
touched by all the well wishes that
we've received over the past few weeks
but tonight tonight it's my turn to say
thanks
whether we have seen eye to eye
or rarely agreed at all
by conversations with you the american
people
in living rooms and in schools at farms
on factory floors with diners
and on distant military outposts
those conversations are what have kept
me honest
and kept me inspired and kept me going
and every day i have learned from you
you made me a better president and you
made me a better man
our our country seemed to be tearing
apart at the seams under his presidency
and it's really amazing that
it came under a president who came in
with the vision
and with the message that i'm going to
bring us all together
i don't think you have donald trump
without barack obama
what is the sad theme of the obama years
here he comes thinking that the force of
his
uh reason the force of intellect the
force of logic
his own biography look man has a very
healthy sense of himself right he
thought that those things would overcome
partisanship
and partisanship has only gotten worse
for too many of us it's become safer to
retreat into our own bubbles
whether in our neighborhoods or on
college campuses
or places of worship or especially
our social media feeds
surrounded by people who look like us
and share the same political outlook
and never challenge our assumptions
i'm sure historians will be arguing over
this for a long time whether it was
because of him
or whether it was going to happen anyway
and he did the best he could to try to
hold us to hold the country together for
these eight years
we sat around in 2009 and said we're in
a post-racial america we got a black
president with a funny name
not just a black president but i mean
the guy's middle name is hussein
who would have thunk right turns out
that not everybody was post-racial for
many people the election of barack obama
was a wake-up call
that their country was changing in ways
that they did not appreciate and like
he brought the white house grace
he showed the world how to hold your
head up
and keep being positive
regardless of whatever critics he has or
not
i truly believe that president obama is
going to go down in history as one of
our greatest presidents
for all that he did and for all that he
tried to do and just for the
person that he is
i think even people who don't like his
policies recognize that
in many ways he's an exemplary human
being in terms of dignity and
family values intelligence and ability
to articulate a world view
michelle
[Music]
for the past 25 years you have not only
been
my wife and mother of my children you
have been my best friend
you took on a role you didn't ask for
and you made it your own with grace
and with grit and with style and good
humor
you have made me proud and you have made
the country proud
he never embarrassed
the united states of america not one
time
in fact you always elevated us often
beyond what we really are made us look
better
to people around the world made us more
of a beacon of hope
than we are even to ourselves and no one
can take that from him
no matter what they say or what they do
and while he was at it he won the nobel
peace prize
i do have one final ask of you as your
president
the same thing i asked when you took a
chance on me eight years ago
i'm asking you to believe
not in my ability to bring about change
but in yours
i'm asking you to hold fast to that
faith
that idea whispered by slaves and
abolitionists
a creed at the core of every american
whose story is not yet written
yes we can yes we did yes we can
thank you god
[Music]
you